تسلا يضرب التزلج ، وقد تم القضاء على أكثر من 60
مليار دولار من
قيمتها السوقية على الأقل قبل
طرحه في السوق وذلك بعد أن صوت الملايين من أتباع إيلون ماسك
لصالحه ببيع 10 من
أسهمه في الشركة التي
انضمت إلي كريستين رومان الآن فقط في كريستين
هل سنناقش هذا المسك ،
لكن بالطبع هنا نحن الآن أولئك
الذين تابعوا هذا السهم
عن كثب نسبيًا سيعرفون أن لديه
فاتورة ضريبية كبيرة قادمة ولكن في ضوء
المحادثات الأخيرة ، فإن
هجمات الملياردير تحب كثيرًا أن تسأل تويتر
ما هي  هل يجب أن يفعل ما يعتقدون أنه
يجب أن يفعله هنا وهو أمر مثير للاهتمام للغاية حيث قام
ثلاثة ملايين ونصف
شخص بالتصويت ، أعني أنه كان هناك الكثير من
الأشخاص الذين حصلوا على
ثلاثة ملايين ونصف مليون صوت على
الأرجح لا أعرف ما إذا كان أي نوع من
صوّت بعض الأشخاص مرتين أو لم يصوتوا ،
لكن يبدو أن الكثير من الناس
كانوا يفكرون في التصويت وكان الأمر مثيرًا للاهتمام أيضًا السناتور رون وايدن ، وهو
رئيس اللجنة المالية بمجلس الشيوخ.  لقد قال بالفعل
متى لا يجب تحديد ما إذا كان أغنى رجل في العالم
أه سيدفع الضرائب من
خلال استطلاع على تويتر
أه لأنه حظي باهتمام كبير أيضًا
أن ما يفعله يسأل تويتر
عما إذا كان يجب عليه بيع الأسهم أم لا
تذكر  لم يمض وقت طويل
منذ بضع سنوات
على تأنيبه من قبل السادة لأنه تأمل في
أخذ الشركة خاصة عبر
تويتر ، لا يوجد قائد أعمال آخر
في العالم متعجرف
جدًا بأشياء مهمة تؤثر على
سعر السهم  مثل elon musk وهذا
المخزون انخفض هذا الصباح بسبب فكرة
أنه يمكنه بيع بعضها وليس من الواضح
متى وما إذا كان سيفعل ذلك بالفعل أم
لا ، لكنه قال إذا إذا صوّت تويتر
لصالحه فسوف يفعل ذلك